you
[Music]
so my name is Kai and today I'd like to
spend the next 30 minutes to talk about
an internal framework called Delfy and
we use this framework to essentially
forecast a blow of metric global
marketplace and a way to get this
essentially to utilize a hybrid approach
what I actually mean with all these
three thinks I just said I'd like to
explain in the next 30 minutes so about
five or six years ago we thought about
how to do forecasting in a global
marketplace
and the fundamental challenge we saw is
that the sheer learnings actually really
good at interpolation because the
universal approximation theorem stays
essentially of either having your own
network an arbitrary number of hidden
layers you can approximate and
interpolate any given function so how
does that then look though when you're
trying to project it out in the future I
really see a fundamental disconnect
between interpolation and extrapolation
because the problem always going to come
down to having on your training set
having really really almost no error but
then you predict it out into the future
there's always going to be uncertain
things happening in the future
so then we spend some time and the main
author of this is a physicist and he
always had the strong ambition coming
from physics that day all those
theoretical physicists out there who
essentially predict the world from a lab
using a theoretical framework to explain
the world and we really really thought
how we can connect those two things and
I mean just to jump on last week what
happened here just leveraged that
excitement is that people were able to
predict how this our black hole would
look like only using theory and to have
that exciting connection to predict
things outside of your data using a
robust theoretical framework this is
what we see as the foundation of Delfy
yes so this is this is then again if you
try to connect interpolation and a
strong theoretical framework to then
have better predictions in the future so
this chart I'll just try to illustrate
how we do have a theoretical framework
that we're trying to understand the
business in but we combine it with
statistical estimation methods to
essentially predict rates and
occurrences of certain events so we
really think that this is a really
strong combination and a hybrid
between those two things to reliably
predict a global marketplace so what I'd
like to spend after I've given you
essentially like a tldr version of I'm
going to talk about the next minutes is
to talk about statistical forecasting
aspect how do you estimate the
seasonality of demand and supply how do
you then also come up with the
underlying metric graph and then how
does Delfy actually give you a single
IRR API to realize versus those aspects
so yeah how does self you realize this
hybrid approach so when we now think
about statistical forecasting there are
many many many models out there so that
she allows you to predict time series
data I mean everybody knows but ARIMA
lsdm seems to be fashionable nowadays
but we always really want to have
interpretive of models because at the
end of the day the only way to have a
tie back into your causal metric graph
this is to have interpretive models what
you also want to gain from forecasting
is to derive business insights from
having the structure model behind it
because if you have a prediction and
trying to explain to executives why I
get to the forecast for this region
they're always gonna ask why how did you
get there
what within the immediate steps that
they might find something to sense you
leverage for product changes so that's
why we always going to prefer
interpretative models of a black box
models one of the most dominant
interpretative model in through yeah
throughout history sadistic sisty
generalized linear model which is a very
simple model that allows you to model a
link function and then you can have an
extensional exponential family that you
have your link in and then you you
essentially have still a linear model
that you can interpret individual
coefficients I have a GL M is is neat
it's simple but it really lacks two
fundamental things that we then found
extensions for one of this extension is
to generalized additive model which
essentially extends to generalized
linear model plus something that gets
the seasonality I mean this predictions
in the global marketplace are highly
driven by seasonality what I mean by
this is you do have different effects
for weeks and years and days of the week
and generalized additive models extends
GLM with this concept I want to talk
about
about this in the next slide what we
also have essentially unexpected events
so things that we don't account for but
we actually see in the data already
observed and they use something called a
generalized linear mixed effect model
that allows you to elevate your
estimation for the future days giving
the existing information I want to talk
about that more in the next few slides
so G this is the generalized additive
model what I want to get across here is
first of all what you're interesting in
modeling is this link function of your
expected value for your response and you
can model it as the sum of smooth
unknown functions what I mean by this is
instead of just having a linear
coefficient what you're also interested
in expressing this covariant through a
basis function and what this allows you
to essentially have a lot more
flexibility that allows you to get to
seasonal trends that are cyclical for
example or cubic to essentially get a
lot more degrees of freedom but it still
fits in the framework of GLM so you made
this interpretive interpretability
as a fair disclaimer I stole this
wonderful chart from a statistic
post on this because I think that done a
great work with gaps and they're great
post about that what's so what we do is
we represent then our seasonality
smoothing functions using something
called a B spline which is basis spline
there's a wonderful art package out
there called mg CV that essentially
realized this and allows you to scale up
to a lot of a lot of data and yeah if
you ever want to use generalized
additive models and are I highly
recommend every CV it's a tremendous
package so now giving I'm giving you
some theoretical understanding but I've
put it's probably best if I walk you
through an exact model let me do I'm
going to walk you through the
theoretical underpinnings of it and then
also how do we think loo this in code so
it would be what we're mainly interested
in is figuring out how many bookings or
nights booked we are expecting so what
we utilize to get an estimate of the
number of nights booked in the future is
that we decompose each booking in two
different dimensions what I mean by this
is every booking we have on the platform
and apologies for European date formats
I realize is too late
but you have someone booking from the
20s of
March booking for a booking in the
future and if you decompose this booking
into three days because the person
staying for three dates you can
represent this as matrix like this so
essentially you have someone going from
the 20th of March to the 25th of March
and he stays one night so this is only
one booking you can only have a one in
this entry and this is how you can
decompose a single booking what you're
also interested in most also tends to be
highly informative it's just a distance
between those things because people have
the tendency to do is being short-term
and therefore you tend to have a lot
more bookings popping up right before
the date so we're trying to estimate
this effect as well by using just the
difference between those two things but
then if you just have this demand driven
approach an estimating number of nights
booked you're clearly missing something
related to supply and this is how we
capture it we use something called the
occupancy index it essentially tells you
how much available good supply is still
free for these individual dates
essentially add not a column to your
model matrix that tells you how much of
the good supply and good is a tricky
concept here I'm aware of this but how
much of the good supply is left of those
markets and you didn't end up with the
matrix that tells you how many nights
booked you're gonna have from we're
going to win and how much of the
available good supplies are used up the
next question is then how do you then
stitch all this together into your gam
so given that I just talked about gams
I'd like to make this connection because
I think it's a very illustrative example
so in here and people are not too
familiar GLM just bear with me I hope
you get the bare bones of this argument
but essentially you're trying to model a
value which is the number of nights
booked
which should be for song process and to
count the occurrences of something
happening what you then are interested
is essentially different and codings
of the day you booked from so if you
think about the 20th of March this will
happen on a weekday and then essentially
how many days have passed since
everybody's inception so we account for
the growth based on a booking date and
then there's several ways you can
encounters you encode this year a year
growth
what you also interested in just known
events because you right now you know
essentially when Easter is gonna happen
and when New Year's are gonna happen and
you're trying to account for that but
just encoding this but now comes the
smooth unknown function that I mentioned
and why we really like gaps so gaps have
this wonderful property that you can
just represent this covariant which is
share of the year which is just a way to
encode this and think about using coded
between 0 and 1 every day of the year
ignoring leap year essentially you get
this then to represent a function using
a basis and this basic basis can have
several properties one of these
properties that we like is having a
cyclical function that because there's a
relation between the first and the last
day of the year as well as also having a
cubic function because it gives you
enough degrees of freedom to estimate
the shape of our seasonality and as I
mentioned you also have Delta which is
the with just a difference between the
booking date and the night this booking
actually happens on we also estimate
this by individual week dates because
this is a highly informative predictor
is giving essentially what day you book
to what week day is this do you then
have the same analog on the date this
night happens on and you do estimate to
share a fear of this as well as the
weekday and you also have events that
happen there and you have a growth term
you then what you do in the last column
of this matrix you take into account the
occupants index essentially how much of
the good supply for the specific dates
is already used up and you treat this as
an offset for technical reasons about
GLM's but let's not go into the veg
detail here but this essentially tells
you how we get to seasonality but we
then also have is something called the
mixed effect model mixed effect model
essentially extends the spare bones of
the most boring general linear model
you've ever seen but a sense it can
extensible not a parameter that you can
treat as a latent variable model that a
crown allows you to essentially estimate
variants for each individual data points
so you don't assume constant variance
you allow for much more much more
flexibility
and we can do this because we have
several observations for future dates
because I have just given you these
combinations so you observe the night's
books that happen on for the 24th of
March from all the previous days and you
can look at the variance between those
observations and the reason why we use
this is essentially to leverage the
number of pre-existing bookings so if
you see at this plot you see three
colors and apologies for not making this
bigger for people in the back but you do
already have a number of existing
bookings and you can see that this blimp
here is just or is a magnitude more than
the other data points around that and
then you can treat this as latent
variable that you do an estimate
variance for each of these observations
and then you do the prediction on this
and if you look at the red color here
you see that if you do not treat this as
a random effect and draw one random
effect for each of these dates in the
future you just pop up the forecast for
that dates slightly but if you use a
random effect you can see that this
plays a much higher role and if you then
lay over actuals
which I can't do here but you see that
this works much better out than than
just using it without a random effect so
what I wanted to get covered so far is
essentially how we use statistical
models to estimate spline demand that
we're using generalized additive model
as well as the mix effect models to
estimate the seasonality and undetected
events on supply and demand and how this
interaction works then using the
occupancy index what now comes
essentially why we consider ourselves a
hybrid approach we are not only
interested in getting the statistical
shape or the seasonal shape of the year
right we also want to have a strong
theoretical understanding of our
business because it allows us to make us
more reliable predictions in the future
as well as allows you to leverage
insights from this model to drive them
business insights and changes in a
product so this is family probably
everybody in this room has once in her
life had to answer the questions how
many piano tuners are there in Chicago
if you generalize this problem this was
essentially introduced but it's
and he really likes to understand things
for breaking it down to smaller
subproblems and using this approach you
can are using this framework you can
always come up with a causal model about
the world because this I still a
wholeheartedly agree believe that humans
are better than machines at finding up a
causal models the debate and statistics
but right now I still think we should
assume and come up with causal models
about the world and using the firm your
family process or treating it as a
favorite problem is a really good
approach to this if we then try to do
this air B&B how many more nights booked
happening on a given date you end up
with some version of this and this is
not the answer
but this is part of the answer
essentially you have nights book there's
the outcome all the way at the end but
to get to this you can take actually
several paths along this metric graph
it's what you can estimate and as I just
walked you through this model is how to
get the number of nights booked but then
the question is how to get to two
bookings well you can't just estimate
something a share model which is doing a
binomial regression that estimates how
many bookings happens per night booked
on a given date by a user type and as
you see we do have the dimensionality
aspect here as we have we cut our users
by past users by past by new users by
past Booker's so you estimate most of
these things in several dimensions and
treat them individually so therefore you
essentially try to realize this metric
graph for different dimensions across
time and this is then essentially
combining those two approaches you end
up with something that we refer to as
Delfy and yes so what does Delfy then
realize essentially the cool thing about
Delfy is that it provides a singular
interface to express both components by
just doing one call essentially so what
you're doing is you specify the
computational engine that allows you to
express this metric graph as well as the
underlying statistical models by a
single function and I'm going to show
some quote later off this but this is
what we built Delfy for because we
didn't see anything out there that
actually realize the same thing
decided to build one single computation
one single API that realizes all this
and what is essentially the output of
this is an airflow DAC and so you can
treat the way we schedule all these
statistical models is that we realize
there's a big airflow tag that has data
ingestion as well as statistical
estimation part of the stack and then
you end up with a DAC that has several
thousand nodes and then you can just
schedule this and any company that has
air flow and what's neat about this is
that you can scale up your your
estimation of these models just
depending on your airflow cluster so you
can scale up your model you just have to
tell essentially increase the size of
this Q in this in this airflow instance
what is also getting produced by the
single API there's something we call the
computational engine why do you need a
computational engine here because at the
end of the day you have this very big
metric graph but you need to still state
it all together you have all these
individual estimates but you need a
place where you stitch it all together
and one of the major benefits of this is
you can do something called scenario
building I'm going to talk about that a
little bit later but I want to highlight
is here we built this first in Python
but then realized that it just doesn't
have the speed that we actually needed
to realize all these computations so we
ended using siphon which essentially
it's Python but you have the ability to
do low level bindings to C and then
you'll be exposed all those all those
sites and functions in Python and what
we then used is we created a GUI on top
of this computational engine and on top
of this air flow graph where you then
have access to this metric graph to use
something we refer to as scenario
building and everybody's ever worked
with finance there tend to be two very
dominant questions which is first of all
the forward going look on your on your
business which is if tomorrow we would
have 10 million more users on this
website how at the end of the year look
like and to avoid all those one-off
Excel models and all of these scenario
buildings we essentially realize this as
part of the GUI so what you can can do
is
I'm going to show this a little bit of
next slide is that you can put your
assumption about the future behavior of
the business into this model and I would
leverage the metric graph you defined as
well as the statistical season Allen
sees you also estimated so it's really
really neat way of how do you combine
those two things another aspect of
scenario building is to backwards
looking which is essentially the goal
scenarios executives really interested
at what would we need to do to get to a
certain exit rate for a specific country
and we we can realise this is also part
of Delfy and to realizing those two
operations there are a lot of them
several approaches to this what we went
with it's essentially you treat this as
a system of equations use a very simple
sick hat method to essentially find a
solution to a system of equations there
are some you could you could have more
structure around that when you think
about ethnicity and things like this but
we currently do not do that so right now
essentially second methods to do
backtracking to this which is very
similar goal seeking but yeah this is
what Delfy is it again it uses those two
aspects it gives you sing a single API
and then it can express your models so
how does system how does this tent
looked like again might this might be
little too small for people in the back
but what you're interested in is a
metric and this metric as I previously
talked about is knights book tour would
be knives booked in this scenario was
the number of knives booked that
happened on individual dates going out
in the future so the date X as I
previously referred to this today you're
staying it but you're not only
interested in this metric we use
something called a fast set which is
essentially a metric on the single
dimension and we then specify and these
individual dimensions you have to also
do the prediction on and what you then
also can do is first of all you need to
have access to a data warehouse so you
gotta implement you have to implement
based on your data infrastructure a data
warehouse operator gets you this data
this is very akin to it and all that
cube but we realize the thin layer on
top of this then you can get this data
into the computation engine
what you then specifies for example that
I talked about in order to predict the
number of nights booked you also need to
know the number
how many listings are gonna have in this
market and you can also specify this as
part of a facet on your nights booked
what you can also then do is to have
this time shift occupancy model that I
previously described from the GAM and
the mixed effect model and you say I'm
interested in this metric cut by these
dimensions that you can pull from this
wet data warehouse and then run this
model to produce a forecast with this
and this will generate you two things
one thing it will generate for you is an
airflow DAC that allows you to run this
model at scale you're interested but it
also builds a computation engine for you
and this is essentially we refactored
all of our code to make it that easy it
used to be much more complicated but now
we're in a place where this is much
easier and it's it's much more readable
I wouldn't have had the confidence to
show how it looked in the period
saturation but now this is much cleaner
and again we tried to make it simple so
then maybe even business analysts or
people not familiar how pies and sites
and air flow works can have access to
doing statistical modeling compute and
using computational engine so this is
kind of what we're trying to move
towards to so this is a very very very
dumbed down version with no interesting
data because giving we do financial
forecasting I cannot necessarily show
you the interesting parts but when I can
show you is a sentient overview of this
GUI we are not a bi tool but in order to
do scenario building you've got to be
kind you've got to do a little bit of a
bi tool so what we ended up doing is to
realize this GUI that is just a flask
app that runs on top of this computation
engine and you can run back and what you
can do here is that you just tell
throughout those dropdowns you can say
what metric you're interested in what
dimensional you're interested in what
scale you want to look
what forecast you want to run this on
essentially we I didn't mention this but
we run this essentially monthly because
this takes a few days to compute all of
this thing but once you've run the
forecast and you have generated the
computational engine with all the
necessary data you then have the ability
from this GUI to essentially tink around
with exits rates for individual metrics
again I had to hide all of several all
the interesting information here but
what you can still see is that let's
assume you're interested in bookings and
you don't care about user type you're
just interested in a total number to the
world and then you can look at the exit
rate by the end of this year and you
will have the ability to play around
with this it's just full disclosure
these are not indicative of our growth I
made up these charts so they have no
ties to the actual data but this is
essentially how we expose this to people
who make them the adjustments because we
have people who are tuned in the
business that actually have an intimate
understanding of what currently goes on
in terms of product in terms of policy
changes and no statistical model will
ever capture this well I would argue it
right now the new statistical model
would capture those dynamics that's why
we always will need to have a human that
still does this like last mile step that
takes an estimated seasonality it takes
something that gets to two events but
you gotta have a human human at the end
of the day to account for one one time
changes and to account for scenario
buildings everything can used to
communicate to executives and yeah I'm
getting to the end of this but before I
finish I would like to essentially
highlight the the man who wrote most of
this with just Marcus he wrote most of
this this has been going on for several
years now we started doing this about
five years ago and been many iterations
on this and this is working on this
requires a rather odd skill set as we
are spread between engineering and FPA
so it's that Marcus is part of FPA and
that we do have engineering resources
who help us with the airflow scheduling
who help us essentially I mean like
getting chef recipes right on the
for worker nodes as well as also
maintaining the computational engine and
as well as having this flash GUI on top
of this because it's what we always
iterating and on us making the
information more accessible and the GUI
because in a day you have to consume
this 3 degree so that's why we have
engineering resources as well as people
who are closer to the business and sit
in FPA and they are spending a lot of
time of getting inputs from all the
different business units to send it
essentially can make those human level
adjustments to walk the last mile that
otherwise we wouldn't do and I know it's
a shameless plug but we're currently
hiring for the CMAs way so if anyone has
any friends feel free to reach out to me
I would also just do if you ever get
interested in this one I read more about
games which i think is a super powerful
modeling stitch stitch fix has a
wonderful blog post about this and
there's always the classical literature
which is assignment words and then you
also have guy man who talks about
Bayesian data analysis which just
brought a grandfather of mixed effect
models and with this I'd like to
conclude and open for questions thanks
just a quick question particularly
around the challenges working with the
cross-functional team yeah especially
with like FPA that speaks a certain
language and you know engineering that
speaks another and you know ml or data
science that you know has this
statistical background like what what
were some of the like like how did you
break through those barriers and
particularly interested in how you guys
got to that the causal relationship that
you showed so in terms of skill set I
think we were looking for a very unique
of people quite frankly actually most
people we have working here in finance
have a background in statistics or
mechanical engineering which actually
they're more kin towards understanding
what we do and quite frankly it's it's a
dialogue that needs to happen between
engineering data science and finance and
just to develop a shared vocabulary and
that actually amounts to teaching people
plans on regression and again this is a
lot of investment but we had tremendous
success using this approach so it's it's
teaching and people who are willing to
learn in terms of coming up with this
collagraph
which always seems to be
the more controversial aspects of this
none calls no causal graph will ever be
perfect of capturing this thing but
essentially what we've developed and
it's a rinse to repeat process you have
one idea and they do a forecast and you
clearly see you're missing one part here
and then you add something there this is
why we now refactor our entire
computation engine to then have more
flexibility of just adding something
there so it's an ongoing rinse repeat
process we be adding models not super
frequent but trying to more frequent but
I don't think we're ever going to be
perfect and it's actually think about it
this way if you're missing something
there's also something interesting
happening a product so actually maybe
you should pay attention maybe something
product change and you need to account
for this now with a new model
[Music]